20 de julio en colombia el día de la
independencia también el día en que
empieza una nueva legislatura en el
congreso y también día de paro nacional
como ven detrás de mí está convocada por
el comité nacional de paro que agrupa
sindicatos y organizaciones sociales y
que pretenden radicar 10 proyectos de
ley en el congreso que tengan en cuenta
solicitudes como la renta básica
educación gratuita y reforma policial
además de esta marcha en localidades de
bogotá en la capital de colombia también
se están produciendo concentraciones de
primeras líneas y es que han venido
primeras líneas de todas las partes del
país esto ha suscitado polémica en los
últimos días y es que desde la policía
consideran que detrás están las
guerrillas mientras las primeras líneas
consideran que se está creando un
enemigo interno a su alrededor
recordemos que esta jornada de paro
sirve para medir cómo está la
temperatura del paro nacional que empezó
el 28 de abril y que ha dejado según
organizaciones sociales más de 70
muertos miles de heridos y decenas
desaparecidos
las denuncias parece que también han
hecho que hagan pequeñas modificaciones
el gobierno como
estrena hoy la policía con nuevos
uniformes azules que den al cuerpo
policial un toque más civil